Welcome to the DOMInvader introduction. I'm going to show you how to use an exciting new feature
called DOMInvader that's implemented as a browser extension and is available in the
BurpSuite embedded browser. This works in both Community and Pro. In essence, it allows you to find DOM based XSS easily as if it was reflected XSS.
And it does this by using canaries, which are just like a random string of alphanumeric characters. And you inject this canary into your request.
So in a get parameter or in a source and the extension will look for this canary in a sync such as a val and report to you in an easy tree view of where this value hit the sync.
So it's really handy and really useful for easily testing websites. So let's get started. The first thing to do is click on the proxy tab.
Open the BurpSuite embedded browser by clicking the open browser button.
Open the open browser.